hey guys I'm in the spin room of the  Reagan Library or tonight's GOP debate  I'm usually at home watching these  things with a bottle of wine but somehow  they let us in I can't believe it we're  gonna be covering the debate for  politics  so you can follow along at Oregon TV  slash Rubin Report and Rubin report on  snapchat and YouTube and Facebook dachau  slash Rubin report all that good stuff  it's gonna be an interesting night  obviously everyone's gonna go after  Trump we'll see what happens beyond that  I expect a lot of fireworks and and we  shall see so following all those things  we're gonna be picturing it's videoing  and what else are we going to do in all  kinds of other good stuff  so follow on right okay